hey everyone welcome to the session on
ci cd anywhere in this session we'll be
discussing why cic gameware matters
and how we're helping customers
streamline their build test and deploy
processes across cloud and on-premise
environments
my name is dominic prunerotni and i'm a
senior product manager at google cloud
and this is my colleague ben houston who
is a kubernetes specialist at google
cloud
today we will be speaking to you about
google's new approach to doing ci cd
anywhere
before i dive into product details i'd
like to turn it over to ben
he's going to give a quick overview on
why a hybrid approach to ci cd is such a
hot topic these days
donovan thanks for your introduction
now to those of you in the audience i
have an important question for you
why should we care about being able to
do continuous integration and continuous
delivery anywhere
well we should care because cicd
flexibility is an extremely important
topic right now this is due the fact
that enterprises need build processes
they can keep pace with constantly
changing business regulatory and
security requirements
and which work across multiple
environments they have made massive
investments in
more specifically enterprises need
transformational development
capabilities like build and ur deploy
anywhere because these can support
massive on-demand skill-up
are inherently resilient and highly
available
can be authored and managed in a
completely version-declared manner
and
are instrumented with out-of-the-box
tooling which provides end-to-end
observability across the entire build
system
unfortunately most enterprises still use
inflexible legacy build tools like
jenkins which predate the cloud
these tools simply can't meet
enterprises current needs because they
don't provide a uniform way to do
continuous integration or continuous
delivery across different environments
and they also can't easily scale to
accommodate the type of extremely high
volume
high concurrency cicd that dominates
modern software development
the good news
is that most of the performance problems
which have traditionally plagued build
systems
have been solved in recent years by
kubernetes which is an extremely popular
orchestration framework for operating
systems at mass and scale
the most highly sought after at scale
system attributes such as flexibility
scalability resilience control and
conformance
are now provided out of the box by the
kubernetes api
its unique approach to distributed
application lifecycle management
next-gen build tools like the one that
my colleague daumoth will introduce next
understand they do not need to reinvent
the wheel
these tools explicitly harness the power
of the kubernetes api
and extend it with rich new primitives
specifically designed to address the
most difficult csd use cases
now that i've explained why kubernetes
is such a big deal for modern csd
let me turn the floor back to dartmouth
to introduce google's new approach to
csc anywhere
thanks ben
with all of this in mind i'd like to
introduce cloud build hybrid
with cloud build hybrid google cloud is
taking the power flexibility and
simplicity of google cloud build and
bringing it to anywhere you can run
kubernetes
cloud build hybrid is powered by tecton
which means out of the box you avoid
vendor lock-in and get the reliability
that you've come to expect from
kubernetes
capabilities like self-healing and
graceful failover allow for no single
point of failure
being able to run directly on your
infrastructure behind your firewalls now
means you can get the advantages of
cloud native ci cd for workloads that
can't easily be moved to the cloud
but cloud built hybrid is not only about
providing the benefits of kubernetes and
tekton
since this is an extension of google
cloud build
cloud build hybrid provides you a
consistent interface and workflow for
building and deploying your applications
you can seamlessly switch between using
the fully managed or hybrid version of
cloud build without having to change
your workflow
you also get a single pane of glass
through the existing cloud build
interface so you can easily see activity
across all your ci cd environments in
one place regardless of whether you're
using the fully managed or hybrid
version
with cloud builds developer centric
syntax you're able to easily define your
csd workloads without having advanced
knowledge of kubernetes so developers
can spend more time on building and
delivering software that drives the
business
and upgrades have never been easier
all cloud built hybrid instances can be
centrally managed which includes
automated updates and patches to make
sure you're always secure
in addition to this with the google
managed control plane you get the
availability and support your business
relies on to ensure smooth operation
with cloud build hybrid we handle the
complexity of multi-environment ci cd
just add environment configuration to
your cloud build yaml and your pipelines
will easily and transparently run the
workload against registered kubernetes
environments regardless of where they're
located
scaling these workloads across your
environment is also simplified
cloud build hybrid harnesses the power
of kubernetes to provide robust auto
scaling and concurrency for all your ci
cd processes
not only is scaling simplified but it's
also more efficient with resource
pooling
all workloads are entirely containerized
and managed using kubernetes allowing
them to be scheduled right alongside
non-ci cd workloads
workloads also run completely
hermetically ensuring that no build-time
dependencies ever cross-contaminate the
runtime dependencies relied upon by
other co-located workloads
for hard-to-update resource-constrained
on-premise environments this scheduling
fungibility is extremely valuable
now let's take a peek under the hood to
see how this works
on the left we have google cloud in the
fully managed control plane
on the right we have a hybrid
multi-cloud environment running a
kubernetes cluster
with google cloud's connect service we
can connect a kubernetes cluster to the
google cloud control plane
doing this we'll install the connect
agent which will allow the control plane
to communicate with the cluster
once the cluster is connected we can
enable the cloud build feature and
install hybrid worker pools
these hybrid worker pools consist of
tecton and some additional components
and configuration that make interacting
with google cloud seamless
once hybrid worker pools are installed
cloud iam will need to be configured for
cloud build service accounts to properly
communicate with the worker pool
and finally we'll need to make sure that
the kubernetes service account on the
worker pool is configured to interact
with our source control and artifact
repositories
once cloud build hybrid is set up you
can leverage the same cloud build
workflow as the fully managed offering
to build test and deploy your
applications
your workload is executed as a series of
build steps which are defined as
containers we call builders
since each build step is hermetic and
only exists for the duration of the step
any data that you wish to share across
steps can be shared through a common
workspace
google cloud provides a set of fully
supported and maintained builders for a
variety of workloads but there are also
over a hundred community builders
available
you can also create your own builder to
address unique use cases
this workflow can not only be used to
build containers but also non-containers
such as java or go artifacts or golden
vm images
the cloud build syntax remains the same
for executing workloads on hybrid worker
pools
all you need to do is specify the hybrid
pool that's going to execute the
workload
for instance in this hello world example
which has six lines of code we specify
the hybrid pool that the build is going
to run on
this build will be transformed into a
techton task run before it's sent to the
hybrid worker pool with optional support
for docker and docker builds
there's a large community that uses
docker today and we want to make sure
the experience for the docker community
is as seamless as possible this means
they don't have to worry about the
overhead of orchestrating docker and
docker build processes in kubernetes
since we take care of this based on the
hybrid pool configuration
the resulting tacton task run in this
example which executes a docker and
docker build ends up being 156 lines
this translates to roughly 26 times more
lines of code
we're taking care of the boilerplate and
kubernetes configuration required to run
this build while integrating it with
google cloud services such as cloud iam
cloud logging and source control
integrations
this allows developers to focus on
building great software and not worry
about the underlying technologies
running their ci sd workloads across all
their environments
cloud build and cloud build hybrid are
part of a much broader end-to-end gcp
devops tool chain
some of these platforms and services
will be highlighted in the demo that ben
is about to show you
ben over to you
thanks dumb
awesome product overview
i'm going to quickly walk through the
logical flow of a short demo we've
prepared
first we'll see a developer check new
code into version control
next
we'll see cloudwood hybrid detect the
code change and begin to kick off builds
then
we'll see four processes concurrently
building and deploying the same
application to four different target
environments
gke antlers attached clusters and aws
and azure and an anti-spare metal
cluster which is running on premise
finally
we'll see the overall build progress
being monitored with built-in tooling
like the cloud operation suite and
cloudable dashboards
okay on the demo
all right
we're now ready for a quick demo of
cloud built hybrid
here we see four different types of
kubernetes clusters registered with a
google cloud control plan
a gk cluster
two anthous attached clusters or eks and
aks
an antho spare metal cluster that is
running on premise
the great news is that once you register
a cluster of google cloud
installing cloud blood hybrid is dead
simple
now we're going to open a cloud shell
session and run a quick cli command to
confirm that our cluster is ready for
action
yep the install status is okay across
the board
okay now that the environment overview
is out of the way
let's quickly explain how cloudwood
hybrid jobs get queued
cloudblood hybrid uses a configuration
construct called the trigger to
associate a build event like a pull
request
with a build pipeline and kick start the
build process
here you can see we have four triggers
defined
one for each of our kubernetes clusters
in a moment we're going to switch to an
id ak an interactive development
environment
we'll commit a config change and push it
to our git repo
afterwards the triggers we've defined
here we'll listen for this commit and
then kick off a cloud build hyper job
for each of our environments
in our ide we see three important files
cloudbuild.yml deployment.yml in the
dockerfile
cloudville.aml defines our build
pipeline
here you can see that we've defined
three steps
build image push image and deploy to the
cluster
next the deployment iemo contains your
kubernetes deployment configuration
here we see that a kubernetes service
account a deployment and a horizontal
pod autoscaler have been defined
finally
the docker file shows what is baked to
our container image
here we pull an upstream engine x image
or an awesome echo statement and then
take a nap
to show cloud but hybrid action we're
going to increase the sleep to 11
seconds
and then commit and push this change
now that our code is committed we'll
switch back to the gcp console where we
see four new builds have been scheduled
each build corresponds to one of the
triggers we showed earlier one for
google cloud aws azure and on-premises
importantly both the ci and the cd steps
are happening at the same time within
each cluster using tekton
now that a few minutes have passed we'll
see that our builds are starting to
complete
next we're going to click on one of
these builds to see what that looks like
here we can see three build steps
build push and deploy
and our build logs
we can also see metadata related to the
build
for example we can see that it ran on
hybrid worker pool gk cluster one
finally i want to show you something
else that's pretty cool about cloudwood
hybrid
if you want to do a deep analysis of
your build bugs these are already
pre-integrated cloud logging
this means that all of your build logs
are already defined with a powerful
common expression language
you can modify as you see fit and then
use to rerun your queries this allows
you to easily dive in and explore any
complex build errors you might run into
now that our builds are finished i want
to show you one more important thing
when we explore the build for another
cloud like aws
we see that the build interface looks
identical to the one we just saw for gk
which is totally awesome
now it's time to check the stats of the
workloads we just deployed
in the google cloud console we see a
screen that shows what workloads existed
in the default gurus namespace of our
clusters before we create a new code
hitting refresh shows that we now see
four new nginx apps running across
google cloud aws azure and on-premise
now just for fun
let's confirm what the dashboard for a
few of the cloud providers show us
hitting refresh in eks shows the same
workload
deployed about five minutes ago
the view from the aks dashboard tells
the exact same story same workload again
this time it's four minutes old
and now we've reached the end of our
demo
we've seen how cloudblood hybrid can be
used to both build and deploy
apps across multiple environments using
tecton-powered kubernetes awesomeness
and select google tooling enjoy
thanks for the great demo ben
to quickly recap you just saw ben show
how cloud build hybrid provides a
unified ci cd experience
that abstracts away the complexities of
cloud native ci cd with kubernetes while
providing the flexibility to build test
and deploy to any environment
google cloud's fully managed control
plane provides a single pane of glass to
gain visibility into all your workloads
regardless of where they're running
finally cloud build hybrids harnesses
the power of kubernetes and tacton to
run your workloads reliably at scale
all of this will be available in public
preview later this quarter
in the meantime to learn more about
cloud build take a look at the cloud
build documentation
and don't forget to check out some of
the other sessions on cloud build cloud
deploy and securing your software
delivery pipeline
thanks for tuning in and learning about
google cloud's approach to ci cd
anywhere
enjoy the rest of google cloud next
you